quand une information provient d'un
média bien établi que ce soit la
télévision la radio ou les journaux on a
autant que faire se peut leurs justes
mais sur internet on trouve à la fois le
pire et le meilleur
et pour compliquer les choses saviez
vous que facebook et même google nous
relais avant tout les informations que
nous préférons consommer qu'elles soient
vraies ou fausses
et ça ça pose un vrai problème comme
nous l'expliquent l'astronaute julie
payette l'une des grandes révolutions de
l'ère numérique
c'est qu'on a maintenant accès à une
multitude de sources d'information on
est bombardé de toutes parts et ce n'est
pas toujours évident de s'y retrouver
pour y mettre un peu d'ordre
les géants du web utilise des
algorithmes qui trie l'information
davance pour nous
facebook convoqué youtube chacun a sa
recette secrète les l'objectif phénomène
nous offrir des contenus sur mesure qui
vont nous plaît
le problème c'est qu'on ne se rend pas
toujours compte des décisions qui sont
prises à notre place et encore moins d
impact
commençons par le plus évident facebook
sur votre fil d'actualité vous ne voyez
qu'une toute petite partie de ce que
font vos amis et c'est la même chose
avec les articles de nouvelles qu'il
s'agisse de politique de santé
changement climatique
facebook fait le tri et chaque personne
reçoit de l'information personnalisée
selon ses préférences que facebook
reflète que nos amis pensent on s'y
attend mais c'est un peu plus surprenant
venant du moteur de recherche de google
un même mot clé ne donne pas
nécessairement les mêmes résultats
par exemple si on tape le mot bouton ça
peut avoir plusieurs sens et google
essaye de deviner ce contexte comment
par apprentissage plus on interagit avec
google + lancé sur nos éventuellement il
est capable de discerner si c'est un
informaticien un couturier ou un
adolescent qui s'interroge sur les
boutons il peut donc offrir des
résultats sur mesure à chacun bien sûr
on aime bien quand ce contrôle
confirment ce qu'on pense déjà
c'est dans la nature humaine sauf
qu'avec internet on peut trouver la
confirmation d'à peu près n'importe où
sur youtube par exemple
même les idées les plus absurdes ont
leur vie on y trouve des centaines de
vidéos de soi disant preuves qu'on n'est
jamais allé sur la lune
ceux qui les regardent s'échangent les
informations et lille et youtube en
rajoute en suggérant des vidéos
similaires
ça crée un petit univers fermé sur lui
même même chose pour ce qui est du
paranormal créationnisme et bien sûr les
extraterrestres des envies d'ailleurs il
y à des experts qui croient que les
algorithmes limite notre champ de vision
écrit ce qu'ils appellent une chambre
d'écho où c'est notre propre voie nos
propres idées qui sont amplifiées un
autre problème avec ces algorithmes de
tri c'est qu'ils accordent beaucoup
d'importance à ce qui est populaire et
c'est normal le nerf de la guerre c'est
la publicité plus il y a 2 clics
q c'est rentable même si c'est
complètement faux facebook et google
tente activement de s'attaquer à ce
problème
mais sur le plan technique c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et ça ne plaira
pas à tout le monde que les géants du
web décès de ce qui est vrai ou faux la
solution c'est d'avoir des techniques de
vérification ou peut-être d'afficher des
mises en garde
comme sur wikipédia dans ce cas si
évidemment ce sont des humains qui
valait l'information et qui souligne les
failles d'un article d'une source au
moins on sait à quoi s'en tenir
c'est la preuve qu'au fond le meilleur
outil disponible pour exercer un
discernement c'est vous sur internet la
télévision la radio dans les journaux
c'est toujours une bonne idée de garder
son sens critique et d'essayer de
valider l'information
un bon truc si au moins trois sources
crédibles et indépendantes disent la
même chose et a de fortes chances que ça
représente le meilleur de la
connaissance avec les outils à notre
disposition
c'est facile de vérifier il ne faut pas
hésiter à sortir de la chambre d'écho à
élargir sa perspective à confronter ses
idées un peu de scepticisme
c'est bon pour la santé et si julie
payette plaisir